well hello and thank you for coming if
he would like to get them
go to this link it's all sitting nicely
and quietly dying in a github repo I
also hate when people start their talk
with an outline so I thought I'd do the
same thing because it always sounds like
they have a problem with this they
overcome something and it ends with
people and pontificating so I'll do
exactly the same sure my name is Malika
which that's tough to pronounce and
spell but I deal with it by day I am in
the same line of businesses Walter White
and by night I consulting spatial and
hyperspectral imager analysis and now
the question is what - who could
possibly drive a chemist to start doing
audio analysis and in 2015 USA there is
only one question it's Obama this year
State of the Union was my 15th since I
emigrated to the US and to me it always
seemed that there is a lot of applauding
which really is not reflective how bad
or good the year was but this year I was
the trimming to quantify how much of a
bloating was there and what were the
phrases and sentences that trigger this
applauding and after with the work my my
suspicions were you know proven true the
Congress did a plot quite frequently
except few boring parts of the beginning
and towards the end I guess when they
didn't want to wake up justice Ginsberg
and they also plotted a lot there that
they are percent shy of quarter length
of the whole address and this has
changed in time because if you go back
to c-span you'll see that you know
Ronald Reagan talked for thirty five
minutes and he was done and nowadays we
are in the age of you know one hour long
State of the Union addresses with 25% of
that spent applauding which is kind of
weird
so that's that's how I started this
whole thing and then while I was doing
that somebody in my Twitter feed posted
a link to a blog post which had
described how you can do song matching
and I skim to the post so spectrograms
yeh Java boo and thought you know let's
do this in in in Python and the research
in this area is quite active you know it
kicked off in the late nineties when the
computers were powerful enough to you
know a this analysis and I remember
reading a paper from 97 it would take
them around four minutes to analyze a
song which is incredible that today's we
have these little slabs in our pockets
which can do it you know in a split of a
second now who's doing this lots of
research groups at various universities
you know old and established companies
like General Electric Philips cells in
this game and quite a few startups so of
course also doing this why would you do
it well it's either intellectual
curiosity or you want to make money by
basically monitoring all types of
streams that are out there and you are
either trying to enforce your copyright
or you're trying to collect your royalty
fees and these are the two main drivers
or sell an app which can settle a
drunken dispute in a bar like what song
is that
and after my research was done all but
one paper followed this simple scheme
they would start really nice you know
let's make a spectrogram I'll tell you
soon enough what is a spectrogram and
then they would proceed to describe
their algorithm which if you're a kind
person and you're in a good mood you
would describe as some sort of rube
golden machine you know something is
moving it's making noise it seems to be
working but trying to follow out what's
really happening in these algorithms is
a mess until I stumbled upon that
outlier it's from Andrew Wang from
Shazam it has a great title and
industrial strength all your search
algorithm you know then
in business when it's industrial
strength right it's I mean text is easy
to read
figures are surprisingly related to what
they're trying to say in text and it's
seven seven pages long now if you can
describe your company's core business
and algorithm in seven pages that has to
be good and now this is a obviously gray
area since you know this is a paper for
which they also have a patent so I will
describe everything that you would need
to do but not assemble it for you so
you're a smart group of people so you'll
be able to figure out what are the
missing links and do it on your own and
back to high school
sound is waves propagating through a
fluid impinging on your eardrum and your
brain determines it as a sound there are
two distinct features that you know as
humans can can distinguish that's the
pitch and humans it's a kind of you know
common thing humans can hear from 20 to
20 kilohertz this depends on age gender
general conditioning of your ears and we
can also of course distinguish the
loudness loudness is measured in
decibels this is a logarithmic scale so
it means that you know standing next to
a jackhammer is 300 times louder than
sitting in a quiet study room human
auditory system also has a peculiarity
that it depends on frequent yes
oh it's frequency yes yeah well do you
know it's most instruments have like
needs physics like they they have that
the fundamental frequency and the you
know the multiplications are multiples
and that's what gives them that amber
but pitch is the building block and
everything else is a combo I mean violin
and saxophone will you know produced at
the same tone but they won't sound the
same because of all these differences in
what they combine and human ear also is
very good at the screening frequencies
and here's a bunch of curves that tell
tell us how much of an energy you have
to pump at a particular frequency to
produce the same level of loudness and
it means that you know for high
frequencies you have to you know put in
a lot of energy compared to the
mid-range frequencies and if you're
wondering why the hell I'm rambling
about you know human hearing when you
know this does not enter the picture of
quantifying songs there is a simple
reason that all you know sound recording
and producing devices I microphones and
speakers in most of the devices are
mediocre at best and usually crap and
now if you imagine how does the song
reach you it's recording in a pristine
studio then it gets messed around a bit
then it reaches the you know that the
radio station radio station airs it it
which is the bar when you in bar you
know puts this music four speakers you
whip out your phone you fire up the you
know the the microphone on your phone so
there is a lot of degradation that goes
on and all these devices are tailored to
be very good at really narrow band of
frequencies maybe you know five hundred
to five you know thousand Hertz and a
lot of is discarded
unless you're an audiophile and you want
to spend you know thousands of dollars
for really high-end equipment and and
that's why I'm mentioning this because
it's important to be aware that the
signal you are getting is nothing that
you will find in textbooks it's pretty
degraded and you and you have to deal
with that nowadays all the music is in a
digital format and it's usually pulse
code modulation which is fancy word for
saying it's sampled at regular you know
sampling points which are determined by
Shannon Nyquist sampling theorem and it
simply says you have a sample twice as
much as the highest frequency that you
have and the intensity of the sound that
the amplitude is recorded as a 16-bit
you know side integer and the odd part
is according to this you know theorem
you know you should find your sound you
know being sampled at 40 kilohertz but
you know CD audio and you know HDMI and
new TVs they're usually at 48 kilohertz
and the reason is all these signals have
to be filtered and the filters that we
have they are not perfect so they need a
bit of a wiggle room to do their work
and they're called you know you know
bandpass transitions that you have there
the other way of describing that the
quality of song is bitrate and that's a
simple matter of figuring out how many
samples you have per second and how many
channels and and this is to illustrate
that CD audio is roughly 1.4 megabits
per second and the best quality mp3
which you get is almost what 4.5 times
less than it so these are the
measurements of of you know sound
quality that you know we have and at the
center of all of this lies short time
Fourier transform and you know Fourier
transform deserves a whole talk on its
own and it's you know one of those
unsung cornerstones of modern society
since they would be no communications
without Fourier transforms and to John's
cool
Tukey and there is a great talk that was
this summer at Pike at idata Seattle but
by William Cox he had a 50 minutes to
explain so if you want to have you know
an overview of Fourier transform go to
this link and watch his dog it's really
great so where would you use short time
Fourier transform and how it's different
from regular Fourier transform if your
signal has frequency that are varying in
time and that is obviously the case you
know for speech for audio also for
encephalo grams and and you know
earthquakes a seismology that they're
also the fields who are heavily using
this and short time s DFT is deceivingly
simple you know you thought you take a
window you know a certain number of
points of your signal you apply
something to them you do Fourier
transform you slide it certain number of
points making sure it overlaps with the
previous point again do the Fourier
transform and do that until you reach
the end of your signal and and that they
always seem to mention or end so you
know there's a lot of why's like you
know how long should this you know you
know window belong you know how much
should we overlap you know why do we you
know do this you know messing with the
signal called a polarization and and
these are crucial especially when you're
dealing with signal of the great quality
so I think this is time to turn to
Jupiter notebook
sure
for mine problem
good
and when I started well I wanted to
start analyzing I realized that I know I
throw away my iPod and I literally had
no mp3s or songs to you know mess around
with so I I quickly you know wrote some
scripts to download from YouTube this is
not exactly copyright friendly but you
know this is for research purposes so if
you don't have mp3s lying around this is
what you should do and I I mentioned
earlier you know that that thing called
spectrograms so what is a spectrogram is
simply put it an image where on x-axis
you have time or more precisely or time
bins of those windows that you had and
on y-axis you you have frequencies and
now each pixel in this image is
intensity at a certain frequency at a
certain point in time which you can
analyze and here is an example of also
really cool in a physical phenomenon I
have three samples of sounds at 275 250
this is pretty mild you can hear
changing pitch and to illustrate this
physical phenomenon I put two signals
you know that that's change meet you
know at midpoint and you can see that
you know once you apply shortened
Fourier transform you are clearly able
to distinguish frequencies when they
switch from one to another but it's
really hard to see the point in time
when I switch and if you pay attention
that kind of uncertainties around point
two seconds and going back to the signal
you can see that my signal is sampled at
11 kilohertz in my window is you know 4k
which is roughly a quarter of a second
and that corresponds to this uncertainty
that you see in figuring out pitching on
is which now if you move to a shorter
window now it's only 1k which means it's
a tenth of a second you can clearly see
that now you can
see we're one single starts in in other
ends or more clearly than a previous
example but you've completely lost the
resolution in frequency and this is good
old Heisenberg's uncertainty principle
people usually think of it as you know
it's all about momentum and time and
silly cat it's really transferable to
uncertainty in frequency and time and
here you have to make your make your own
trade-off what do you care more about
differentiating in time or
differentiating in frequency or as it's
usually the case you make a trade-off
yes/no to two notes at a time so it
starts 300 and 275 and halfway through
it switches to 300 to 275 and 250 if it
just drops by 25 Hertz and moving back
oh you know how does you know this music
looked like when you look at it how does
something that sounds really cool and
nice like this when you look at its
digital presentation it's basically not
a squiggly line and why do we mess with
it one of the important facts about
Fourier transform it has to be symmetric
the signal has to be symmetric and
periodic and this is anything but
symmetric and periodic and to make this
you know to kind of massage it into this
form that's why we apply those windows
calling you know a polarization where
you take another function you multiply
your you know signal segments with this
function in order to make it somewhat
symmetric and periodic which now you can
fit into your FFT if you don't do this
FFT hasn't nasty you know properties
that it will start giving you really
weird signals if it's not following this
established you know math driven problem
and they also tell you or you take the
you know two types of windows Hamming in
a hand and you overlap them by 50
percent like why like well I don't know
that's what my daddy told me and it
turns out there is a reason why you
would overlap by 50 percent it is these
two types of windows some to constant
when they overlap or fifty percent so
now you see that you know you have a
pretty flat top and why is this
important is if you have signal like
this and you do this you know
apodization you get signal that looks
like this and you're using a lot of you
know of signal and power at the tail end
but if you overlap it by 50 percent
you'll be recovering this signal and
power in the next iteration and since
it's all a constant line it means that
once you're done with analyzing your you
know spectrogram you can do you know
inverse short time Fourier transform and
go back to the original you know song
sound
and this is also now we'll be switching
to looking at spectrograms of songs
actually and it's always good to look at
your data you know you would expect data
to be nice and clean but it never is and
this is a spectrogram of one of the
songs that I downloaded and you can see
that the signal is completely gone after
17 kilohertz
so it's wasting space and giving you no
information about a song so what you
would probably do is just clip this
useless part of the song that you have
and now once you have something that
will probably look like this
question starts how do you now somehow
encode this in a way that can be
quantified and used for you know some
sort of classification or or IDN scheme
and it's simple but you know instead of
thinking of this as frequencies and
times and intensities think of this as
an image so an image you know there are
always no peaks and troughs and most
likely no Peaks are the ones that are
important so you simply go looking for
Peaks in your image and once you
establish the scheme which you would
like to look you know how are your Peaks
found you can see that you know these
are some points there and looking at one
song compared to another you can see you
know there is some difference but you
know you'll never be comparing whole
songs you'll be always having just a
time slice which is a part of the whole
song it would be really hard to have
some you know pattern matching
algorithms because you know it's not
that easy to to achieve and what you do
now once you kind of have the positions
of all these peaks that you determined
relevant for that and how do you
determine you know which Peaks are
really relevant in what
not that that's a whole engineering
problem you want your your scheme to be
relatively robust in terms of noise
coming through so you you probably
should set some threshold in terms of
you know peak intensity relative or
absolute so if your signal gets degraded
you you have enough robustness that you
know noise is not starting to come true
and you also want to have some spatial
separation between the peaks because if
two peaks are really close they're not
giving you that much info globally what
you would really like to have is a lot
of you know Peaks spread all over as
much as you can because this increases
then the entropy for system and then you
know that the more entropy you have
there the easier it will be to find out
what you're looking for and now the next
step is how do you transform this into
something that you can use for for ideal
and one of the beauties is everybody has
some scheme of how to spatially locate
these peaks and the easiest way is you
pick each peak you throw a forward
looking quadrant or space of any shape
that you would like and say all the
peaks other Peaks that are captured in
this you know quadrant or space they're
probably related to this peak and now
you establish this you know pattern of
Peaks that you have but you know this is
not enough because the the thing is all
songs kind of sound the same for one
reason or another but that's the we'll
be getting to that and now once you you
have all these peaks pick up you can
start somehow hashing them and you can
see it's very easy it's easier not to
hash them as a is a group of Peaks but
you know hash them is pairs so you would
take the the frequency of each of peak
pairs record those two frequencies
together
add also the time differential that is
separating those two peaks and pass it
through the hashing function of your
choosing or liking so that you know step
one is very easy and if you have her had
misfortune to sit around campfire and
listen to annoying guy with ponytail in
guitar you know that also on sound the
same but the the reason is you know all
artists you know kind of you know follow
or are inspired by another so it's not
uncommon to find you know a set you know
number of tunes or notes reoccurring in
many different songs I mean that that
that's what you would expect I mean
music is just combining you know a
limited set of notes into something
that's that's unique and this is the the
beauty and simplicity of their algorithm
now that you have the whole song you
have your slice with you know but you
would like to kind of identify which
song it is there is one thing that is
common to you know correct pairing of
this time slice and whole song and that
is you know that hash that you found it
might be present not only in this song
but in many others but what is unique
about this song that all hash is found
in this you know search time slice
compared to the whole song have the same
relative difference between the
beginning of the search time slice and
the whole song
and again this me explaining sounds kind
of you know confusing and this is again
part of gray area where you know but if
you you know like using sequel databases
you can do this fairly easy with two
simple tables so you need one table
where you store your songs song ID and
song name and your finger table where
you store your hash again your song ID
and that off the time and now what
happens it's search time so you have
some search hashes write your query will
recognize and find all the hashes so
you'll have hashes that are the same but
with different song names then the next
kind of query that you do is you know
find me the hashes that have you know
these hashes and also this time you know
relative time difference and then each
hash found with song name will also have
a tag of that relative time difference
and now you can pull or make a simple
histogram of you know song ID
how many hashes found how many times you
know time difference is found and the
correct song will usually have the
highest number of these you know time
relative time differences and that's you
know then you can think of you know what
scheme would you use to describe is it
winner-take-all you know do you have
some certain false positives false
negatives that you would like to to play
around and it's also funny and this is
always you know kind of surprises me
that the power of Python all of this is
achievable with baseline functions why
not you know one liners which you can
find you know in side P reading audio
matplotlib make a spectrogram cycle
image will find those Peaks for you and
I'm talking again if you use short name
you know variable names all these
functions can fit within eighty nine
seventy nine in your care
in your line and you don't even have to
go to you know sequel database if you
want to see how this works instead of
you know having sequel database you can
have your hashes and everything stored
you know in dictionary then again you
can do a simple you know Python hash you
can intersect your sets and voila you
know the you know big multi-billion
dollar company like Shazam can be
represented in you know five lines of
code which is amazing you know I it's so
nice to see that business can be made
out of simple things now once you have
this working you know that the famous
question but does it scale well that's
you know more of an engineering question
you know how how big your data size at
the end will be you would probably have
to optimize search time and network
traffic because everything that you know
you do locally is you know bound by you
know hard drive seek times and all that
stuff and there are two kind of caveats
with this algorithm is you cannot mess
with you know a place beat because
you're relying a lot or almost
exclusively on the positions of those
you know Peaks and the hash marks which
are encoded in that and if you speed up
a song or slow down a song it will be
thrown off because your database will be
recorded well database will be created
with let's say you know play speed one
but if radio sometimes radio stations
actually do that they kind of like you
know speed up music just enough that it
will throw off the detection and there
is a small wiggle room of around you
know one to two percent how much this
can be tolerated in your database before
the search is start going all over the
place and what is also new is you can
with loud the artist who lip-sync on
concerts because if you compare you know
hashes from a recorded you know studio
album
and hashes from a live concert they're
never the same you know if you get
around 70 percent of you know
correspondence that's really good it
means that the band knows how to keep
its rhythm and and the singer can do the
same but if they hit for their live
concert you know the same hit rates as
you would find in your city they're
cheaters they are lip-syncing and that's
it all I have to say thank you very much
for your -